There's a very interesting article in The
New Republic, which we're going to link to.
The article is by a for.
And we've we've talked about Matt Ford's work
before, and it's often very, very good.
And in this New Republic piece, Matt Ford
talks about the reality that there is, quote,
no real substantive defense to these charges,
the charges against Donald Trump.
Americans watched Trump spread lies about
the elections four months before the riot.
He warned in dark and ominous terms that the
country was in danger and his supporters needed
to fight back, Trump said at a rally outside
the Capitol on January 6th.
You'll never take back our country with weakness.
You have to show strength.
You have to be strong.
We have to come to demand that Congress do
the right thing and only count the electors
that have been lawfully slated, lawfully slated.
He also even praised his supporters after
they trampled themselves and beat up police
officers as, quote, very special.
So this is a situation where the facts are
abundantly clear, and yet Donald Trump is
going to portray himself as the victim in
these proceedings.
The main line, as Matt Ford writes of defense
from Trump's lawyers, is that the impeachment
trial is that invalid because Trump no longer
holds federal office, but also that Trump
really here is actually the victim.
Trump has been victimized on free speech grounds.
Trump has been silenced.
Trump isn't being allowed to speak.
This is a form of censorship council culture,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, and that Trump
is being tried in this manner, stripped of
First Amendment protections.
Now, of course, that's a ridiculous argument.
House managers already put out a brief about
this and they explained that the First Amendment
is there to protect Americans from having
their free speech infringed upon or curtailed
by the government.
It's not there to protect members of the government
from their speech.
Having consequences.
Speech has consequences.
That's part of free speech.
And so at its core, this is simple gaslighting.
And I know that at this point, there's so
many people, particularly on the American
right, who instantly become triggered when
the term gaslighting is mentioned.
This is not this trial is not going to be
about the Trump attorney team putting together
a credible defense.
The entire idea of Trump as victim who has
lost his free speech rights is about putting
up a smokescreen so that most I don't want
to say all, but most Republican senators will
see if any vote to convict most Republican
senators can vote to acquit and hide behind
this and say it wasn't.
And actually part of today being about whether
the trial is constitutional is set up so that
you can have Republican senators vote to acquit
and say, listen, I didn't even think this
was constitutional.
I did my duty.
I think the entire thing was farcical.
It was unconstitutional.
And I voted to acquit.
And this is a very common thing that bullies
do.
It's a common thing that narcissists do.
They are the perpetrators, but they pretend
to be the bullies.
Authoritarians are always the victims.
Strong men are always pretending to be the
aggrieved.
And we've seen it with Kim Jong-Un.
We saw it with Hugo Chavez.
They are all endlessly the victims forever
and ever.
And that's what Donald Trump will try starting
today at his impeachment trial through lawyers
by arguing the entire thing is unconstitutional.
Trump's out of office.
This all can't happen.
Once we get to the actual trial, they will
argue that this is a matter of speech and
censorship.
And Trump is being victimized here by, you
know, take your pick, the media, Democrat,
whatever.
Just pick, pick whatever you want.
And at this point, I would be surprised if
you were surprised because Donald Trump has
been playing the victim forever.
During the 2016 campaign, he was constantly
whining about how unfair everybody was to
him.
The media's unfair.
Democrats are unfair.
Nobody's treating him properly.
And I mean, I have a I have a sort of a I
don't know, a sort of macabre, detached curiosity
to see how wacky and deranged the case made
by Trump's defense lawyers is going to be.
And by the time you listen to today's show,
by the time you watch this clip, we will probably
already have a sense of it, because the impeachment
trial starts today.
We will have coverage and much more about
this on The David Pakman Show Instagram page.
Make sure you're following us there at The
David Pakman Show.
We will take a quick break and be right back
after
the
The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman Dotcom.